[Music]
hey you guys time once again
for tomes of terror where i talk about
horror books
now the book that i'm talking about
today is
a goddamn classic uh i will say because
the book is so
old and because the film that is based
on the book is so old
there will be spoilers because i kind of
feel like
most people probably know the story of
this so i don't feel too bad about
spoiling it and i do actually kind of
want to talk a little bit about
uh the differences between the book and
the movie adaptation
which are surprisingly few i guess it's
not that surprising but we'll get into
that in a little bit
the book that i'm talking about is from
1973
and it is by robert marasco and it is
called
burnt offerings now this is actually my
second read of this book i don't know if
you know but this is actually a pretty
uh classic probably one of the big five
i guess haunted house
novels um you know that get brought up a
lot as being really influential
the other ones being obviously the
haunting of hill house by shirley
jackson
the shining by stephen king hell house
by richard matheson
and the house next door by n rivers and
rivers
sit-ins uh all of those books are
excellent
and are all very um influential we're
all influential like in the haunted
house kind of genre
and i feel like burnt offerings is
probably like the least
known and the least red of those and
that's really a shame because this is
really really
a great book and easily like i said one
of my favorite haunted house novels
of all time and you can totally tell
that stephen king
used this book as sort of an inspiration
for the shining
i will note too that sadly this book was
out of print for a very long time
but good old valoncourt books who are
awesome
uh put out this edition that i have here
with this this cover is like kick-ass if
you can't really see it it's kind of
like a face
which i didn't even notice when i first
bought it with like the trees growing on
top of it and stuff
they put this out in 2015 and it has
uh an introduction by stephen graham
jones
who's written a whole bunch of stuff and
also wrote night of the mannequins with
the novella that i talked about
a few months ago so it's a really nice
addition and i really like that they're
kind of bringing it maybe back to the
forefront because like i said out of the
big five haunted house novels as they're
sometimes called
i feel like this one is the least red i
feel like a lot of people like horror
movies
horror fans i guess have like seen the
movie which came out in 1976
but i don't even know if a lot of people
know that it was based on a book or
you know read the book or whatever now
how i ended up
reading this the first time was i don't
know like stephen king he wrote a
non-fiction book called dance macabre
uh we know way back in the day like in
the early 80s and he was kind of talking
about it's all about horror about horror
movies about horror books you know
horror tv shows just kind of like horror
in culture in general from 1950 to 1980
with some kind of side ways stuff back
about uh you know the classics of
literature like frankenstein and dracula
and everything
now at the end of that he had this
massive list
of books that he hadn't really talked
about all that much in the text but
books that he still like recommended
so he had this really big long i think
it was like 50 books or 100 books or
something it was like some ridiculous
amount
and for whatever reason when i was a
teenager in my early 20s
i said to myself i'm going to read as
many of these books
in this index as i can get my hands on
and one of them was burnt offerings now
at the time
like this was probably the mid to late
80s i want to say
somewhere around that area and i don't
know if this was out of print at that
point
i actually ended up checking it out of
the library and i really really dug it i
think i had seen the movie first
because i think i the first time i saw
the movie uh and the movie is one of my
favorite haunted house
movies from the 1970s it's just really
good karen black
oliver reed it's just a really good
movie and uh
i saw it at a slumber party
for my friend tanya we were staying at
her house me and a bunch of other girls
i can't remember who all
else was there but we were watching
burnt offerings
and if you've seen the movie or read the
book and you know about the chauffeur
uh that turns up in this like and some
of the we were all like
pretty freaked out by that i mean you
have to until we were only like 12 or 13
at the time
so i think the first time that chauffeur
like appears on the screen we all just
like ran out of the room screaming
because it was like so upsetting
but it's like if you've seen the movie
you know what i'm talking about that's
like super super creepy but so i'd seen
the movie first so i kind of knew it was
going to happen but that even made me
more
curious about what the book was going to
be like
now interestingly robert marasco from
everything that i could determine
he was a a teacher and this book
was actually originally written as a
screenplay
but then it was sort of turned into
novel form now robert marasco as far as
i know
this book and he wrote another earlier
book called child's play it was nothing
to do with the chucky movie
it was kind of about like a
psychological horror thing about
students and teachers he wrote that like
earlier but i think those are the two
only two books he ever wrote which is
kind of a shame because this is like a
pretty kick-ass
book so if you don't know the story
behind it
the novel follows a family the rolfs uh
marion and her husband ben and they have
an eight-year-old son
named david now this family uh ben is a
teacher
and marion is kind of you know
stay-at-home mom or whatever
and they live in this fairly small
apartment in queens
uh back in the day when you could
actually afford to live in an apartment
in queens on
a teacher's salary and no other salary
was the 70s
so there you go so they live in this
apartment and they
go away every summer but they usually
just go you know upstate new york or
whatever
um but this year marion has decided you
know we really need to
get away from this place you know the
apartment is very noisy it's you know
dirty
it's like there's always good so she
always has kind of something to complain
about
and she finds this ad in the newspaper
and they're basically like okay well
there's this house and it's really
remote and isolated it has a pool it has
like you know beach or lakefront access
and it's very reasonable for the right
people that's what it says
now she gets very excited about this
and ends up showing it to ben and ben is
just very skeptical he's like look one
we haven't seen this house
what is very reasonable mean what does
the right people mean it's like this
really doesn't sound good he's trying to
talk her out of it he's like you know
what's
what's wrong with going you know upstate
and staying a little cabin up there for
two weeks like we usually do
and she's like no no i really want to do
this and she
finally finally pretty much nags him
into
at least going up and looking at the
police so
they drive two hours up to this house
this house is indeed very isolated and
it is not just a house it's essentially
an
estate in that there's massive like
acres and acres and it's like something
like 200 acres
like that of like gardens uh there's
like a you know cottages there's a bay
there's all this other there's a boat
house
there's all this stuff and when they
first drive up to it they're like this
can't be
it this can't be reasonably priced and
ben's like yeah there's no way even if
it's very reasonable we're not being
able to afford this [ __ ]
and honestly the first time they drive
up to it they think that what's being
rented out
is this crappy looking little uh you
know cottage that's on the land that
apparently the
gardener used to live in or whatever so
ben's just like no we're turning around
and going home right now this is a
stupid idea um
it turns out that he's right but he is
kind of cranky about it but finally
marion's like please can we just
you know go and talk to the lady she had
talked to the lady on the phone
roz allardyce and uh she's like you know
she's expecting us so they go in there
and they meet raz allardyce and her
brother
who is mostly just called brother i
think in the movie he's called arnold i
don't remember if they ever refer to him
as arnold in the book
but because mostly she just calls him
brother and these two there's also a
like a groundskeeper caretaker type of
dude uh named
walker who's kind of uh a pig but you
know what i mean
it's like at least very say that so
these two like the brother and sister
the allardyces
are pretty weird and pretty eccentric
not necessarily in a threatening way but
just in a real kind of like hey these
are kooky old people kind of way
and uh because ben's like you know the
cottage looks like crap and it's like we
want to know what the price is and
everything and they're just like
uh initially they say seven hundred
dollars but then they say nine hundred
dollars
nine hundred dollars to live in what is
a thirty room
mansion for two months like essentially
the whole entire summer like from july
first through
uh labor day now the mansion
is kind of run down but you know it's
just this massive there's so much
so many like beautiful things in it like
all these antiques and everything
and marion's just going around like
gagalite like looking at like oh my god
i can't believe they have all these
gorgeous expensive things and they don't
really take care of it because
everything's kind of covered with dust
and everything's kind of peeling and
stuff
and she immediately feels an affinity
with this house and she just will not
take no for she's like we are going to
do this
so i mean at 900 for a whole summer
in a mansion on an estate with a pool
and everything like that they're like
yeah that's pretty reasonable
and uh so they talked to these two weird
siblings that own the house and ben's
just like man this house is like so big
it's like how we gonna take care of it
it's kind of falling apart what if
something bad happens
and he's always just trying to think of
like the worst thing but mary's just
like no please please please i really
want to do this
and they kind of go back and forth about
it but then the brother and the sister
because ben's like what's the catch it's
like there has to be a catch and at
first the brother's just like no no
there's no catch but they're like oh
well
yeah there is one tiny little catch but
it's not even that big of a deal
they're like basically our elderly
mother who is 85 years old
will be staying in the house over the
summer with you
but she stays in her room all the time
and it's very likely that you will never
see her because she's very very private
all we ask you to do is take her a tray
of food
three times a day take her some
breakfast take her some lunch take her
some dinner
and that's all you have to do you will
probably never see her
and it's just not even that big of a
deal so with this
ben is kind of like well that's even
more [ __ ] up because like you know
there's an old lady what if she dies
what if something goes wrong or whatever
it's like no no it's gonna be totally
fine
so like i said they go back and forth
but finally marion gets her way
and they end up taking possession of
this house
for the summer now the thing about this
house
very much and you can see how stephen
king was really
influenced by this book and also by the
haunting of hill house
which i think that robert marasco had
also read the haunting of hill house too
because
stephen graham jones in his introduction
for this
he's basically saying well okay there's
two kinds of haunted houses like in
novels there's a haunted house where
something bad happened there's ghosts
and then there's what is called a hungry
house which is what hill house is
which is what they overlook and the
shining is and is also
what this house is this mansion
essentially what it is he doesn't spell
it out exactly
but it's pretty obvious that what this
house does
is that it's able to insinuate its way
into the people that are staying in it
and sort of attacks their weaknesses
you know or you know knows enough about
their weaknesses to know how to get to
them and it's essentially
draining their energy to restore itself
because when the family first comes into
this house
like i said there's all of these
beautiful things in there it's a
beautiful house
but it looks like it's kind of been let
go to rack in ruins like no one's really
cleaned it it's like you know not really
maintained
but as the weeks go on as the rolfs are
there
and ben in particular starts acting
uh really violent and he has these kind
of blackouts like there's one point
where he almost
drowns his son and he can't really
remember why he did it
there's one point where he essentially
almost like rapes
his wife uh and doesn't really remember
he has like these blackouts
they end up bringing uh ben's aunt
elizabeth who is in her 70s
and she was real spry and and everything
before she came to the house but then
she just starts getting sicker and
sicker and she can't like move
so the house is just like draining
everything out of everyone
and then things start essentially fixing
themselves like the first thing that
marion notices
is that the swimming pool which was kind
of [ __ ] up and brown and like you know
the
the paving around the pool is all
cracked and uneven
but she notices one morning when she's
looking out the window she's like oh
well now the pool is clean
even though ben hadn't been able to get
the the filter or the pump working
correctly she's like the pool's now
clean and all of the
paving stones and stuff like that around
the pool are now
just pristine and that happened the day
after
ben freaked out and almost killed his
son like they were
they were kind of horsing around in the
pool and then he just kind of
like a red film goes over his eyes or
whatever and he just like starts
freaking out and like slamming the kid
down in the pool
and later he just feels really bad about
he said i don't know what happened i
just i wanted to kill him and i don't
know why
and so it's the house working on
everyone insidiously
now it's draining uh the other three
members of the
family ben uh you know aunt elizabeth
and
the kid to a lesser extent i feel like
the kid
he doesn't really factor into the story
too much just to kind of be he's eight
so he's kind of
the one that's always getting endangered
uh at one point the house
makes ann elizabeth or implies that it
makes aunt elizabeth go into his room
and turn the gas heater on and then lock
him in there and you know they they save
him before that happens
but the house is kind of trying to get
rid of them however
marion the house has essentially done
what hill house did to eleanor in the
haunting of hill house
it is making her feel like this is her
house this is her home this is her place
and it's her responsibility to take care
of this home and make sure that it comes
back to its own
to its former glory now i will note that
she is very very
strict about none of the other members
of the family are allowed to go
into mrs allardyce's mother allardyce's
she has a sitting room and a bedroom so
marion goes into the sitting room like
to leave the tray
like for the old lady that's supposedly
in there and most of the time
the food is never touched the only time
that the food is touched and it looks
like somebody came out and ate
was when marion starts to suspect that
there might not
actually be anybody in there it's so the
house is kind of like stringing her
along but nobody ever sees
this supposed old lady that supposedly
lives in this bedroom which is like
super super creepy and that was one of
the i think that was one of the things
that creeped me out the movie uh in the
movie as well
but the house is taking over marion to a
point where she starts wearing mrs
allardyce's clothes like that she finds
in the sitting room
she starts decorating the sitting room
all pretty like she finds all these
amazing
like all this i mean like gold
candlesticks and like crystal and she
finds and she
just spends all of her time working on
this house and cleaning everything and
making everything beautiful
even though and her family are just like
where the [ __ ] are you it's like we're
supposed to be
having a fun summer like hanging out at
the bay or swimming in the pool or
whatever and she's always
in the sitting room just like sitting in
there staring
or cleaning something or something like
that so she's just become obsessed
with fixing up this house even though
in a lot of ways the house kind of fixes
itself as it drains the energy from the
other
family members so that's kind of the
whole story of it
is this house is essentially like
a living organism that restores itself
by draining people's
life energy turning them against one
another turning their weaknesses
against them things of that nature but
there's always kind of one caretaker i
guess
because it's implied that this is you
know the allardyce is the
the people that own the house that have
done this lots and lots of times
because they find like all these in one
of the rooms they find all these
photographs of the house
like looking really awesome that look
like they go back like a hundred years
so every so every year or every two
years
they have somebody different stay in
this house and they're like hey we're
going off on vacation you can rent the
house out for cheap
and you know horrible things happen uh
in the house and the house
like restores itself over the summer and
there's little there's nice little
subtle
indications of the past stuff they don't
go too much into it which i think is
good but you know it's like ben
finds a broken pair of glasses like the
bottom of the pool
uh when they first get there david the
sun finds like a tricycle with some
blood on it like in these bushes
and stuff like that but that's kind of
as far as it goes so you know that it's
been done a bunch of times
and then there's also all these
photographs of people
in mother allardyce's sitting room and
marion is like looking at them and she's
like man
you know these pictures go way back you
know again like a hundred years or
whatever
and she's like the the expressions on
the faces of the people in the
photographs
are really disturbing like they look
like they're really scared and stuff
so it turns out and i don't remember if
they did this if they had this in the
movie or not
but in the book it turns out that
all those pictures are people that had
stayed in the house and the house had
essentially drained them or killed them
or whatever
because at one point and as i said
there's going to be spoilers so
don't get mad at me because like i said
this book is as
damn near as old as i am and the movie
is almost as old as i am too
so it's like you know if if you haven't
seen the movie or read the book then
probably go do that and whatever but at
one point and elizabeth
who has been you know getting sicker and
sicker and weaker and weaker this whole
time she eventually dies
and marion freaks out because she goes
up to the sitting room and then suddenly
the one of the photographs
is of aunt elizabeth so all of these
people
in these photographs are obviously dead
and like the house had
drained them and used their energy to
restore itself so interestingly as i
said the movie
adaptation which came out in 1976
is alarmingly faithful to the book i
mean it's almost
exactly like the book there's only a
couple changes that were made
which like i said i guess is not that
surprising because the book was
apparently written by robert marasco
first as a screenplay and then he
novelized it
and then i guess essentially they went
back and made it into a screenplay again
so it's almost exactly the same i'm not
saying that if you've seen the movie you
don't have to read the book because
obviously those are two different
experiences
i'm just saying that you know there
weren't really a lot of changes made and
i think that was a good idea because
it's like a really good novel it's
really creepy it's really insidious
i really like the slow build-up of like
what the [ __ ] is going on in this house
like who's like
is that old lady really in the room like
what is this house doing
every time somebody you know every time
the kid falls and scrapes his knees like
you know
a plant in the greenhouse will grow a
new shoot and stuff like that so it's
like i
really really like this kind of really
stately build up of the weirdness
and it's also really cool too the way
the house gets in between
everybody like because it divides
everybody like i said marion
uh you know as soon as she walks in the
house like before they've even rented it
she's like yeah this
we're gonna have this place and she just
will not take no for an answer and just
kind of nags and nags and nags
and wheedles ben until he finally gives
in even though he doesn't really want to
and he thinks the whole
situation is suspicious i mean obviously
he doesn't suspect
that what's gonna happen because why
would you but he just thinks there's
something weird about the whole
situation he doesn't like the allardyces
he thinks they're weirdos
and he's like i don't like the idea of
having to take care of this old lady who
we don't even know
and uh you know and it turns out that
he's right but marion's whole thing
is the house sees that there's kind of
an underlying implication in this
that marion because she wants something
that is so far above her station
i guess because it's like she is the
wife of a teacher
uh you know they have a kid she's kind
of a stay-at-home mom they have an
apartment in queens which i guess isn't
a [ __ ] hole
but it's not like i think she aspires to
grander things so as soon as she comes
into this house she's like yeah this is
the kind of life i deserve
and she just becomes obsessed with it so
it's just kind of like
her entire obsession with i mean and
it's even named in the book like when
it's from her point of view she's going
around saying oh it's she knows the
names of like all the
you know the antiques and like you know
what bran like all the vases and
everything like that she knows what
everything is
so you can tell that she's really kind
of aspirational in that sense and that's
exactly what the house uses against her
and it gets to a point where she is just
so obsessed with the house that it
becomes almost like a living creature to
her
and she gets to a point where she
doesn't really give a [ __ ] about her
family anymore which like i said is one
of the main things that was changed from
the book now one of the things that
is uh that's not in the movie but is in
the book
is that there's actually at the
beginning of the book and this isn't a
long book it's only like 250 pages or
something like that the beginning of the
book there's actually a large amount of
time
spent with the raw family in queens so
they're trying to establish
how this apartment is sort of how marion
feels about living in this environment
like even like i said it's not a
[ __ ] but it's noisy
you know there's a there's an old man
that like pees on the
mailboxes in the lobby it's like that
kind of [ __ ] it's like you know living
in new york city and she's
she doesn't like it and she thinks she
deserves something better which is why
she just keeps pushing and pushing that
they need to go somewhere
so you know like i said she's very
aspirational so a significant portion of
the not a significant portion but
probably like the first quarter of the
book
is the family in queens and them
and her and ben going back and forth
about renting this house so they do kind
of go a little bit more into the back
story i believe in the movie
which uh they moved the location of the
movie to california because that's where
the
you know the mansion was that they shot
uh so they're making it like that's
where the summer house is but the book
is actually set in
new york city like i said they live in
queens and the house uh that they go to
is actually i think on the eastern end
of long island i think is where it's
supposed to be like just this real
remote estate
uh so they did change that they took um
the movie doesn't have any of that stuff
i think it pretty much just
starts with her being like hey here's
this ad let's go check this out
um i don't think they they spend that
much time with them before they go to
the house
another interesting thing they changed
was toward the end now like i said the
book is almost identical to the movie
but the book i was actually reading um
grady hendrix has a really great blog he
did a book called paperbacks from hell
which is nonfiction and he kind of talks
about a lot of the
pulp horror the paperback war that came
out in the 70s and 80s um
and i have the book back there but i
haven't read it yet and but i'm really
looking forward to it but he has sort of
a blog where he talks about these kind
of forgotten bestsellers
and one of the ones that he talked about
was burnt offerings
and in there he said something really
interesting he didn't really care that
much for the movie but
he was talking about how good the book
was but one of the things that he said
in his uh breakdown of it that i thought
was really interesting
he said the book is so much more
cold-blooded
than the movie and i know exactly what
he's talking about
in the movie the same [ __ ] happens where
marianne gets obsessed with this house
and starts to neglect her family
and starts to care less about them
because as i said she's just
become obsessed with taking care of this
house and uh
essentially becoming mrs allardyce
because spoiler alert like i said there
there actually really isn't a person in
that room it's just kind of like a force
and it kind of takes over a person every
single time and then they become the
next one
sort of uh but in the movie she it's
like towards the end there's a scene
where uh the kid like falls in the pool
or the bay or something like that and
starts to drown
in the movie marion kind of snaps out of
the ship for a second
and then like jumps in and saves him in
the book that does not happen
in the book what what ends up happening
is that ben
has seen he saw like the chauffeur that
he sees like uh
it's a recurring nightmare from his
childhood that freaks him out
and he you know in the book and in the
movie like he sees the actual chauffeur
in the car like the funeral car or
whatever
and he sees it in real life and it
starts freaking him out so he kind of
thinks
it feels like he's losing his mind too
and he finally sees it in real life
after aunt elizabeth dies it's this
horrible traumatic thing and he just
kind of goes into like
catatonic sort of state so he's sitting
by the pool
and his son is drowning and he can't
move like to save it so in the movie
marion like rushes and pulls him out of
the pool
but then both ben and david die later
when they're trying to escape like the
house falls on them like you know or
something like that or bricks falling
from the chimney
so they do actually still die in the
movie
it's just that marion actually tries to
save
david but then they die later in the
book
the same [ __ ] happens with ben catatonic
sitting on the thing watching the kid
drown but the kid just drowns and marion
doesn't
lift a finger to help him so that's i
think that's what um
grady hendricks meant when he said that
it was cold-blooded
meaning that marion just kind of thought
about it for a second oh david's dying
eh
don't care like she did she gave like no
shits
at this point so this is the way the
book is structured is really interesting
because it jumps back and forth
it's not in the first person uh but it's
kind of like omniscient third person i
guess
so it jumps back and forth between all
of their perspectives
uh sometimes in the same section which i
thought was a little weird because
usually it's
you know usually if you're jumping from
perspective to spec perspective
you would go to a different section it
doesn't necessarily always do that
but which i thought was kind of strange
i don't know if i've read any other book
like that where the perspectives like
shifted
like like i said you'd be thinking of
things like marion's thinking about
things and talking and then suddenly
she'll be talking to ben and then it'll
go into ben's uh you know
what he's thinking about so it'll kind
of move over to him without changing
sections
and it's a little bit weird but i guess
i don't know it wasn't like hard to
understand or anything i just thought it
was a little strange that it did that a
couple of times
without you know making a delineation
but as i said that's not even a
criticism because it didn't bother me
and it didn't
you know it's i just said it was unusual
that's like not something you see a lot
uh but yeah so if you have not read
burnt offerings
if you've seen the movie and you want to
read the book like i said they're very
similar but there are some differences
you know it's not really the the case
that even though
the movie is so similar to the book it's
like oh you don't have to read the book
then because
that's dumb you know the movie's awesome
but the book just has
i don't know like more detail more kind
of [ __ ] more
like what's going on in people's heads
uh which i think is particularly
interesting in the case of marion
because you can see
her obsession growing and how how her
caring about her family just starts to
be like eroded away
until at the end she's just like
whatever i don't give a [ __ ] what
happens to him i just want him to go
away
uh so it kind of so that's kind of cool
too but i like that it's shifted
perspective
you know ben thinking that he's going
crazy because he's like
he starts to realize what the house is
doing but then he's like that can't be
what's happening because that's what you
would think in real life
uh you know and then he starts seeing
the chauffeur and he starts seeing these
other things and he just like starts
wigging out
so it's really fascinating not only the
insidious nature of what the house is
doing
but just the fragmenting of the family
unit
and like you know what's going on with
all of that and i just i love the
concept
of a house that is like an intelligent
organism like i said
in a lot of ways this was very very
influential to the shining which like
you know
the overlook does pretty much the same
thing like drains people's energy and
uses that to like you know sustain
itself this is kind of the same thing
except the house gets run down
and then it needs new blood new meat
like to come in there
and then every time like they start
getting hurt or dying or going mad or
whatever the house like just
drains all the energy out and starts
kind of like making itself look gorgeous
again
yeah if you haven't read it like i said
the vallencourt books just did a new
edition
in a new ish edition in 2015 with a new
introduction
and i would really recommend it i really
feel like
more people need to read it because
it was just so influential and i feel
like it kind of got forgotten about a
little bit even the movie is kind of
forgotten about um but
maybe not as much as the book like i
said i think a lot of people might not
even know
that that 1976 movie was based on a
novel
so i would definitely definitely
recommend it one of my favorite haunted
house
stories of all time easily and i was
really really happy that i got to
reread it again because i haven't read
it for probably 20 years
you know for this show and that was like
i said one of the things i wanted to do
was reread some stuff that i hadn't read
in a long time
and this was definitely one that was on
my list so
check it out it's awesome and i will see
you guys on the next one
bye